Ekaterina wants to know what role does
internal culture play in the company's
success can you give one concrete tip on
building that culture you can Tarina how
are you doing it's always great to hear
from you I'm glad you're on the show
company culture is actually you know
it's funny it's funny this questions
coming up today I actually on the way to
work today said you know what the book
that I'm gonna write that's really gonna
like but you know I always think is
crush it who think economy's gonna sneak
up on people I know as I sit here today
the book that I write on culture and how
to build an organization through humans
not CFO cash tactics is gonna be my book
legacy so whenever I get to that so it's
everything to me
as an operator I'm all EQ over IQ the
one concrete tactic I have is way too
many people make decisions on who they
fire or hire based on money oh we have
the budget to hire another designer or
camera person or like it's it's a
financial decision all my decisions on
hiring and firing are emotional what is
it gonna do to the collective community
you know if I fire this person who's so
popular internally because they have
great people skills well that hurt
everybody else and can I can I push that
person into another direction to help
them get another job over 90 days
instead of firing them abruptly in one
day that costs me a lot more money but
does a hell of a lot for me in the
culture and so that is my one concrete
kind of curveball I haven't heard a lot
of people talk about that kind of stuff
example